يقرع جرس المدرسه هنا رغم انه يوم السبت
يروي الطلاب الى صفوفهم في اليوم الاول من
عطله الاسبوع في برلين الصفوف هنا ليست
اجباريه فالمدرسه هي مدرسه لتعليم اللغه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
السعوديه
الى المانيا ياتون الى هنا مره في الاسبوع
لتعلم القراءه والكتابه
العربيه لازم اعرف احكي واكتب بالعربي
لغه الدين عندي لانه عربي لازم اعرف
اقرا قران منيح عشان هيك لازم اعرف اقرا
لغه القران لغه الام وبحب احكي عربي
التي تعلموا العربيه هنا ايضا يقولون
بانهم يريدون لاولادهم ان يحافظوا على
لغتهم ولا ينسونها الاء الموجوده في دمشق
وصلت الى المانيا قبل خمس سنوات وتعلم
ابنتيها العربيه في هذه المدرسه
كلها باللغه العربيه تقريبا
هذا الشعر كثير
يمكن لانه انا عم بزرع فيهم محبه اللغه
العربيه ومن خلال التواصل دائما مع
اقربائه بالعكس بتستمتعه يعني وثلاث ارباع
وقتهن بعدين بالمدارس الالمانيه بتخاف مثل
اي ام بيخافوا ان اولادها ينسون اللغه
العربيه
من خلال القصه السوري
ثلاثي حصص مختلفه يوم السبت والاحد
90% من الطلبه العرب من القادمين الجدد
اهاليتهم يرغبون بالتدريس ابنائهم اللغه
العربيه للمحافظه على ثقافتهم وجذورهم
وايضا همم لسهوله التواصل مع اولياء
امورهم في اقربائهم تنتهي الصفوف ويغادر
الطلاب ومعهم بضعته كلمات اضافيه كل اسبوع
يامل وذويهم ان تبقى معهم حتى يكبروا
لتذكرهم بجذورهم وثقافتهم رغم العربيه
بنين